welcome to a brand new episode of not
too deep I'm your host grace and Helbig
the first we have Taryn Manning with us
on this episode and it is so wonderful
she is so cool she's so like just I have
no other word than to say cool she drove
up here from Palm Springs already cool
on a weekday to record this episode with
us and we talked about orange is the new
black we also talked about that time
that she got um tackled by a bodyguard
on the premiere of crossroads the movie
with Britney Spears you've heard of it
if you haven't get ready it's a
hilarious story
I enjoy this episode of not too deep
with Taryn Manning hey you I bet you
have a great idea would you like to turn
it into a reality guess would I have
someone that's gonna help you do it it's
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project with
you're showcasing your work or selling
products of any kind with beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about anything you can easily make
a beautiful website all by yourself but
if you get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help go to squarespace.com slash
Grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain so one of the
questions I like to start off asking is
what's the question you hate answering
the most how do you get started caring
oh yeah you can go okay well we won't
talk about that at all then let's talk
about Palm Springs what's your favorite
place in Palm Springs
Holim Paulo Springs first of all I like
to prance tell ya its phonetics I like
that there's palm trees in the middle of
the desert yeah how did you get settled
down so many yeah um well I feel like I
was I was a tragic a tragic first
Coachella goer oh really you went to the
very first Coachella yeah really yes Wow
number one
okay and then probably about eight eight
consecutive years of just bliss so it
you know it's switched not saying this
switches bad sure just changed uh-huh I
mean and I guess my friends like to tell
me that I I would say at nineteen I'm
gonna have a house here one day it just
came true that's amazing yeah you you
did the secret thoughts I think the
secret yeah I mean I didn't know that
but I knew that you know I wanted a nice
house so you know it's affordable well
okay
I've never been to Coachella it's like
um that's a great question
I don't know exactly why how are you
from I'm from Jersey originally and now
I live out here and my friend and I have
a place in Palm Springs where the
Governor's Ball or any type of no I
haven't done any of that
I think I'm building myself up to go to
Coachella because we've talked to so
many different people that have been on
here about going what is I want to know
the the neon carnival yeah I like that's
a that's like it not Coachella though
yeah that's after yeah right what is
that well it's a party that's
after-hours so when you're just not done
raging and you got neon carnival videos
are friends den you know Jenn Rosario we
love them we've been raging with them
since you know 2003 or something yeah
they're just still going strong so for
people that haven't been what's your
best piece of festival advice mm-hmm I
would say don't buy your bracelets
anywhere but the proper proper you know
source okay because I've been caught
before
not knowing I'm like what do you mean I
have counterfeit bracelets you know an
ID cuff you like take it places I'm like
I'll just cut them off it's not worth it
just sweet way I'm so sorry but you
can't just jump over the fence
- shush but it's like everybody did
three there's so many people like just
take my bracelet I just can't do it
anymore
yeah and then you know people like make
their bracelets baggy and stuff but I
gotcha I would just say um be prepared
for not be prepared for like don't have
your expectations too high because it
looks like reasonable it's not saying
you know it's that thing where it's like
everybody wants to run this way and not
only they schedule things like just when
you're getting into a band or group they
schedule it so you're needing to leave
that group to go rush elsewhere and it's
just a frenzy of like ants
ya know the photos and videos look
insane yeah there's no relaxation you're
really selling yeah I mean it seems like
constant stimulus correct time yeah ad
calm um I want that sign me up I'm going
down for it there I I'm gonna try next
year I think we'll see let's see how it
goes okay yeah maybe stagecoach is more
for you that feels like the way to ease
into it that's just a one fine weekend
three days of cow cowboy hat babes every
was more my speed this stagecoach yeah
stagecoach and babes and beauties like
it's more consistent would you ever
start your own festival yes really
mm-hmm I love that I feel like you
should I feel like that's on the hose
into that though is so epic yeah it
seems like it's an easier thing in
theory than actual practice probably
November Woodstock
yes I don't physically remember I wasn't
physically there build it they come yeah
they feel their dreams I do and fire
fest yes did you go down to that not
subscribe to that
yeah sometimes they'll go back over my
budget okay well speaking of music you
have an original song in the upcoming
season well by the time this comes out
in the season that's already out of
orange is the new black yes I do
exciting I know it's so cool um yeah
it's a song that I wrote
one fine day just doing a tribute to my
character and wanting to thank Genji and
Tara and Neri and annalisa and all the
producers that I adore just saying thank
you for what they'd done for me that's
super sweet yeah wait so you made the
song or like by itself and then they
used it in the season yeah that is so
cool
yeah I sing it acapella it was kind of
like a like a poem if you will and just
like I sang it and I never expected like
I sent it so genuine like hey guys just
wanted to say thank you for everything
for the last seven years and then
suddenly yeah I was like a whole a whole
thing and we want to use the song and I
had no idea that would happen that's so
cool that's so sweet
yeah but just shows another thing in
life that when you you know it was just
another lesson like because I I do music
you know who cares right because I try
too hard and what-have-you and so like
you know I'm always producing things and
things and things and then the one time
I don't care so much about being hurt in
that way that's what I'm like the gifts
come when things happen yeah yeah I
think that's true for a lot of things
but that's yeah I think people don't
realize about you is that you are like a
multi-faceted artist like across the
board like I was looking into your music
you have that song the light it just
came out yeah which is really beautiful
and like kind of like hauntingly
beautiful and is that for you just kind
of more of a release the music side of
things hmm yeah at this point um well
it's just sort of a necessity but also a
release yeah okay so talk about this
season of orange is the new black
because we've heard very cryptic things
you have yeah such as something crazy
happens to your character
and then all we first well you know
there's this something that's going
around that I'm sure many people have
heard about which is like an an opiate
opioid addiction meant at all what have
you mm-hmm
nothing that I have ever dabbled into I
remember that when I got my wisdom teeth
out I was given vicodin and I just like
was itching itching itching like so I
don't totally understand the the the
epic you know this is a huge worldwide
yeah problem right now yeah and of
course you know how to go out like that
Wow so I was a little upset you know
just as far as like tearing goes but you
know as far as pennsatucky goes she goes
through the you know goes through a
really hard time because she actually
want what's better for herself it gets
into school and and she is excelling and
excelling until the teacher gets fired
mm-hmm and then when he gets fired any
teacher comes along that doesn't really
care and she just feels like she's gonna
fail the test her GED test and so she's
just one of those people that gets in
her head you know and and some of the
girls are using this fentanyl stuff she
starts on it doesn't go so well for her
mmm-hmm that's terrible so she passes
away Wow that's all it is it's like yeah
that's how quickly things happen yeah
that's so nuts did you have to do any
sort of like emotional prep on your end
to say goodbye to this character no
because I feel that she wasn't prepared
at all to pass like that and like she
never was prepared to to feel the way
she felt to make her want to even dabble
with drugs again remember she was like
in a mess right so it's like a whole
different yeah I'm excited to addiction
and um it was just kind of a punk rock
move on her part she just saw the girls
doing that she was upset there was a
comment made
she's like that reactionary so hmm it's
that quick and it's tragic because you
root for her Mike I think there's a real
soft sweetness side of her that
something that people are like rooting
for which others will do some people
don't you know it's like a lot of people
like sort of well there's just so many
people I can relate to this right yeah
you know and it's just it's just so
generic to me like if there's one thing
that if I could speak on just what a
terrible terrible crisis that they I
don't even know how to say that opiate
opioids like yes addiction is just so
awful yeah I mean there must have been
an educational experience for you to
realize like how widespread that is and
also that's going to be a lot of
pressure to play this character that
deals with this when it is so like
prevalent in the real world yeah I just
feel like that I keep giving me like
this huge damage me more I have a whole
nother horse of another color issues I
do it have you guys ever heard of just
kidding I must be so intense but also
this set just from seeing like behind
the scenes footage and like seeing you
guys post online and things like that it
seems like the energy of everyone on set
is always so wonderful and supportive
wow that's so sweet that they pretend
that no I love that show no I'm just
like come on like you know what though I
will say this this is no joke yeah there
is such a camaraderie that is so
consistent and just kind and and I
there's a bunch of women that know that
we're women and every day fluctuates and
vacillate so there is that sort of
understanding that I've never come
across that's so cool it's real and it
also feels like everyone's super
appreciative of this because you know
you don't get these kind of
opportunities all the time to be in
these sorts of environments but that
many wonderful personalities and it
feels like everyone's not taking it for
granted I think you just nailed it
spot-on I think that we would be idiots
like yeah looked a gift horse in its
face and you know even if Terrence being
a butthole or so-and-so's being you know
a sugar just like I'm so happy for today
for that reason so we you know there's
just so much respect I think respect is
a word yeah that's super cool everyone
does their own thing you know
yeah but I think everyone really yeah
they just kind of value the experience
yeah versa and that comes through and
everyone's performances and ever like
the show in general it's just like
really wonderful even though it's tragic
didn't bleak and yeah it takes you on so
many different emotional roller coasters
it's still really cool to see J yeah
they were all just like seeing dude game
good game good game
they're Smiley's okay we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back I want to
talk about your many doges that you own
and animals in general so we'll be right
back with more not too deep this episode
not too deep is brought to you by our
biggest supporter is that's a pun you'll
get it with more than 70 sizes including
their signature half cup sizes third
love designs bras with breast size and
shape in mind for a perfect fit and
premium feel you just answer a few
simple questions via third loves fit
finder quiz to find your perfect fit in
60 seconds then thanks to third loves
100 percent fit guarantee you can wear
you can wash and you can put your bra to
the test for 60 days and if you don't
love it you can return it and third love
will wash it and donate it to a woman in
need it's hands-down the most
comfortable bra that you'll ever own
with straps that won't slip tagless
labels and lightweight super thin memory
foam cups I hate wearing bras I wear
sports bras all the time you know this
but I the only actual bras like I really
have like the bras when I like getting
fancy our third love bras because they
feel as comfortable as sports bras feel
to me and third love knows there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they're offering you listeners 15% off
your first order go to third love calm
grace now to find your perfect fitting
bra and get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love.com slash grace for
15% off today would you like to turn
your dream into a reality well you can
with Squarespace because they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project are you looking to start a new
business do you want to showcase your
work do you want to publish content do
you want to sell products or more
Squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can make a beautiful
website all by yourself they also have a
very powerful ecommerce functionality
that lets you sell anything online and
analytics that help you grow your site
in real time everything is optimized for
mobile right out of the box and there's
nothing to patch or upgrade ever buying
domains is super simple and you'll get
the help you need with Squarespace is
24/7 award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people I'm talking
about designers lawyers artists gamers
restaurants gyms to turn great ideas
into something real so head to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of the website or
domain again that squarespace.com slash
grace offer code grace all right let's
talk about your animals that are
currently down in Palm Springs
all right you have penguin happy tales
curly lamb and Thunderbird how did they
get their names first of all I'm so
penguin penguin got her name because I
watched march of the Penguins right I
got her yeah she's my longest standing I
had her said she's a puppy and what are
their breeds oh she's a Maltese King
Charles Cavalier spaniel cool that's a
mouthful she's she's from my ex-fiance
that's like the best thing that came
from her she was not a rescue okay so
just to be clear but she is something
else so then moving right along when I
was in New York I was going to the pet
shop every day to get penguin her food
mhm and there was this black cat that on
the you know the animal place
the animals food plays like hosted a
rescue every month okay so this cat and
I'm madly allergic to cats
uh-huh was this there week after week
after week so week four I'm like hey you
know guys what's going on with the cat
but every time I'd go up to her she
would just look me dead in the eyes are
horrifying beauty our tune yeah the
first time she's stunning I'm always
like man if I was a cat I want to look
like you like she's like she's like a
stunning Panther yeah but apparently
she's gonna be euthanized because it was
right along the time of Halloween oh wow
so they were talking to me and they're
like yeah people come by and they say
they're gonna take her but no it takes
her and I'm like so what does it take to
get her you know just fill out this
paper here and I'm my own man paper
named prey you know it's like three
lines yes like nothing like now can't do
it too much no I was like it's do this
filled it out and then I told her listen
lady you listen to me at dinner and her
yellow eyes like you and I I'm just
gonna get you out of here and then I'm
gonna find you a home if she's like fair
enough so then I got her home that night
and she crawled all over the apartment I
mean up high in the rafters like
everywhere you go she broke a glass and
then took her you know they have like
four paws and yeah I'm here like do claw
she took that paw off uh-huh
so I'm ever here in the glass break we
have the glass she yeah so she kept she
loves to hit she used to love to hit
things off the shelf yeah and it
happened so much that you just like cry
wolf cry off right yeah so then there
was one proper side like back and I knew
something broke I'm like a just what
another breaking another breaking glass
yeah if I was like but there's no
meowing and so I get up and there's like
a trail of blood all the way to the
bathroom and she's cut her little back
paw thing oh it completely off its
uh-huh so next thing you know or in the
carrier like so you and I were just
gonna go to the vet
and then I'm just taking you back you
here so it turns out we went through all
these like you know bonding things
together and and then I just couldn't
she was like a good girl yeah she just
became my cat and I love her so much and
I'm not allergic tour really it's a
craziest thing yeah well kismet yeah
maybe yeah so I just I read I I'm dander
her all the time or whatever like I just
get all her
yeah the furminator for whatever sure
and I just like brush her so you
traveled with her across the country
back and forth how was she traveling
he's good oh yeah she's used to being
like tossed around you know ChaCha so
that's penguin and Thunderbird okay I
was at 2 and then I bought my house in
Palm Springs and I wanted to foster
animals so I was like all right let's do
this so the very first two dogs that
were ever brought to me such a whim
I'll take them as soon as like somebody
threatened to you know adopt him on my
home to provide them a permanent so so
they're bonded pair one of them was
blind pretty much and they kind of like
she uses her as a guide
they were found together and it's
splitting them up would be like a crime
one lady wanted to take one one the
other and it just didn't seem right yeah
now I have three white fluffy dogs and
one black cat what are they do they have
different personalities oh my gosh yes
really I find yes
what how would you describe each of
their personalities oh my goodness
um-hmm well first of all they all love
to eat okay
man they're just all so different in age
they're ever-changing yeah do they get
along with each other they love I tell
you all four of them oh so much it's
it's like it's it's like nothing I can
explain yeah I can't even fit right in
but I'd bring in another dog in the cat
run so it's like these four are meant to
be together yeah do you foster other
animals in between I've been trying but
I have to put them in like different
area
okay because not because it penguin and
curly are happy but because the cat just
like freaks out but okay so curly curl
is my my my guard she's my my security
okay she will stay up all night so she's
so she's one of the ones that was tied
to the tree for ten years of her life
though they're all ladies by the way Wow
yes I have a to old lady died he was
like the Golden Girls that yeah she she
will stand until she's like wobbling oh
go to sleep
she's like no mom I'm on duty it's my
job like she's just on her own program
she's a professional and she looks happy
sleep and then happy is the real like
kind of manipulating one that's like
I'll go get his food buddy you stand out
guard and then she goes and like will go
pick up the scraps and although our
penguins just like like I get food at
noon always I won't of course dude like
bring them to set ever I've never
brought all three no not all three no
okay there's still time
there's there's such a there's such a
parade that it would be like and it's
their movie yeah have you ever traveled
with all of them together yes oh man and
I had four different human beings that
you have to have four different put them
under the plane oh no yeah you know yeah
no terrifying to me oh right so when
they travel in a plane they have to get
their own seats yes yeah like you know
one human being per dog okay that's
hilarious do they get like anxious when
they're separated um happy and curly do
but penguins like penguins like are they
gone great that's a frozen like she's so
bummed that died I brought them in but
she accepts them but she loves just her
a long time oh that's sweet yeah they
sound hilarious they're funny good do
what's okay what's like your normal
morning
like if there is a normal morning for
you ah a normal morning like when I'm on
at work or not our let's say not at work
would you go to like what sit how do you
relax um
normal mornings are great there you know
I I wake up very very early to let them
out you know for their by the way
because I had to retrain them how to go
to the bathroom outside oh really so
that was rough like I just bought my
house and like she was so contaminated I
was like oh my gosh it really bummed me
out and so slowly I've turned them
around and so we have such a strict
routine like a parent I'm very strict I
don't mean I'm just like I will set my
alarm to get them outside because I just
see such a difference when I keep them
on this schedule yeah penguins are you
kidding me Mom like did you stay there
going out so I keep them on a schedule
so pretty much because I was working in
New York for all those years like I was
three hours ahead yeah so I wake up like
5:00 a.m. get them outside I would wake
and then they come back in and I'd wake
up and you know answer my emails and
such go outside and lay out for a spruce
of sign yeah in Palm Springs and then go
to the gym out there and just live the
super leisurely like slow life enjoy
whatever happens yesterday I've never
been to the gym in Palm Springs what's
that experience no one's there very
mellow and yeah there's like no traffic
it's like it's just a whole different
misfeed yeah it's great
okay I love it I'm in so you know about
it I know a little bit about it um okay
what's coming what's next what's
happening now are you taking a break are
you working on other things I just got
back from Virginia I just did a movie
there yeah I'm just I'm just like
honestly like auditioning for the next
part really yeah that would be great
getting some offers but there's things
that I really want so you have to look
hard yeah is there a type of character a
role that you haven't played yet that
you'd love um oh for sure yeah yeah I
would
- yeah I just love to play somebody
that's been through a lot which all my
characters have been through a lot of
stuff they're very layered and no matter
how much I try to be play like I'm
innocent they always say like you know
she just has she just looks like she has
a world of you know life in her short so
I feel like I would be best served in an
inner role like an FBI an FBI agent you
know some type of CSI detectives some
type of bounty hunter some type of you
know like Silence of the Lambs Jodie
Foster type of oh yeah I mean I just you
know as we go in life we kind of
discover like who we really are like
what they always say like you'll make
your fortune doing not maybe what like
your passion is but what you find
yourself doing all the time and what if
I wasn't doing all the time is trying to
crack the code of like why why why why
you know those things those go on and on
and on but you know like right here I
have passed for wrong I know I've been
looking since tattoo yeah why am i
hacked all the time like you know so
it's just like why this isn't something
that happens
yeah happens all the time well everybody
well yeah yeah yeah but you know you
know then you can just have a certain
type of person after you that's just
very tech savvy so you just spend your
life trying to you know just big prevent
that from happening but then you learn
so many things by default so then you
take on these whole different on I mean
you just find that what you're
interested in is so vastly different
from what you're doing for a living true
yeah you know if I could integrate what
what really moves my like spins my wheel
into an acting role I think that I will
be living my true dream yeah sounds
incredible and I think that just like
you know some type of character that
that's just you know maybe a little
paranoid slash
you know she's been through alive it was
she's been to prison and back and also
she's just helping to fight crime not a
snitch though yeah but just sort of
helping to fight crime call a shape or
form that'd be really cool for me that
sounds awesome
I think that can happen for you so
what's the type of shows that you watch
I don't really like like victim he shows
it's it's more I watch a lot of
documentaries oh yeah yeah I think I've
seen every documentary Under the Sun I
love to learn that's a great quality of
a human being yeah I feel like there's
always things to learn and yeah what
have you seen any good ones lately oh
wow yeah so many I'm so lately let's see
what the last ones are I'm a I'll go
like on to YouTube and just I'll go deep
into the into the matrix yeah
oh stuff um I like a lot of crime
documentaries like I like I said that's
very like you know Caucasian women in my
age bracket trendy right yeah I love to
learn about about health you know I like
to learn that there is a cure for cancer
mm-hmm and I like to watch open-heart
surgeries really yeah just hydrogen
peroxide curing cancer I like to watch a
root canal I'm not sure if really saw
that Wow no that was no was removed off
of Netflix immediately basically it's
all about that if you have a root canal
you pretty much will dive some type of
cancer not really chore if you have that
yeah why did they take it off of Netflix
because it was too honest
well because dentists were going out of
business no I don't so it's really hard
to find I happen to get to see it
literally before it was taken down yeah
so it's all about just root canals and
then that takes you to another thing
which takes you to another and you know
it's just I'm gonna down the rabbit hole
of knowledge that's super cool also I'm
going to look at working at media week
by noon
it was like blacklisted
Wow that's so nuts well okay
I don't but now I'm so nervous about
maybe maybe I do I don't know it's like
if you have a cavity I guess I got our
name you know yeah well that's good I
haven't been to the dentist in a couple
years so good to know to put that on my
to-do list okay we take one quick break
and then when we get back we have
Twitter questions for you the lovely
cyber swagger Twitter heard of it yeah
okay we'll be right back we're not you
deep if there's something interfering
with your happiness or preventing you
from achieving your goals better help
online counseling can help they offer
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues such as depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts LGBTQ matters grief
self-esteem and more connect with your
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment and get help
at your own time and at your own pace
anything you share is confidential it's
so convenient you can schedule secure
video or phone sessions as well as chat
and text with your therapists and if for
some reason you are not happy with your
counselor though you can request a new
one at any time for no additional charge
best of all it's affordable our
listeners get 10% off your first month
with the discount code grace so why not
get started go to better help calm slash
grace then simply fill out a
questionnaire to help them assess your
needs and get you matched with a
counselor that you'll love that's better
help calm slash grace okay before we get
into these Twitter questions I'm gonna
ask you the two questions asked every
single guests that is on the podcast and
the first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at oh
my goodness
cold spaghetti mm-hmm it's not like is
that like mean no I mean it's really
your intention it's up to you people
have done it in a celebratory fashion
in a rewarding fashion okay let's see
hmm
I probably want to throw that print for
dying in an elevator yeah buddy
[Laughter]
okay the other question is not the other
question every guest is to tell us your
worst pants [ __ ] story or like a
close call but you can only should
happen should happens but you can only
tell us in three words or three small
phrases so like mine is college jogging
front lawn ten roller rink skate country
oh okay no follow-up questions there
okay let's get into these Twitter
questions some wants to know has a
die-hard fan of Boomkat what's your bro
up to these days is it a band that you
had with your brother yeah I wish I knew
she's get a hold of them let me know got
it what's it like making music with your
family it's magical yeah really is yeah
it's like just those like that same sort
of frequency that UT can hit together
yeah that's awesome I feel like I could
go one of two ways
yeah and then there's that that is my
brother yeah a lot of people are asking
what are your feelings on oranges new
black ending um I feel you know I feel
as I I was like wow that's quick but at
the same time and I also believe in like
kind of you know going out while while
things are just still still mean
something yeah and and also you know all
good things must come to an end sure
sure sure and also I mean by that when
we're recording this it hasn't
officially been out yet so I'm sure
there's going to be another wave of like
saying goodbye to as soon as you see
everyone do you look at like the
responses online of people from the show
at all yeah I definitely do it's also
positive it's it's so overwhelmingly
powerfully positive that it's like I
think I personally think that everyone's
devastated yeah like yeah it's it was
just it's almost for me The Simpsons
my family yeah you know but they're
still there all the time I just I think
that there'll be lots of you know people
watching it again and again but
hopefully people will follow us and what
we continue to do in our careers I think
so I mean this has had such an impact
that I don't think people are gonna drop
off just because they I'm sure other
girls will go it deliberately
play something so opposite starring in
Cinderella the live-action they'll be
just so not believable right you know I
watch it someone to know do you remember
the last time you fell out of bed no
okay think about this or myself too yeah
maybe yeah yeah I was young but I do
remember it but it was I was very young
okay good he's actually pushed out of
bed by a bunk bed I was just staying at
you know as you know spending the night
at a friend's house and she thought it
would be funny to push me out as a joke
but there was like a drawer opened up so
I fell on that like my back was like
yeah but yeah that's that's why I
remember what a fun fries I have fed
today low to the ground because of that
specific incidentally someone to know
what's your favorite skittle flavor pink
know pink is a big shot starburst that's
starburst orange oh really you don't is
that weird
I like all of them I think I haven't had
a sort of taste of like maybe the same
and we're all being duped so let us know
if you went to prison
what kind of inmate would you be and
what would you most likely go to prison
for oh heavens
oh sorry it's a I answer that answer
that online it's a political caller I
get calls from my home town like once a
day
really yeah it makes no sense to me yeah
you're on this family yeah unless it's
the FBI agent that's hacked into my
phone it really wants to connect well
let me figure it out let's see here so
prison I think I would be very quiet but
if I had a fight I would at least hold
my hands up over my head and protect it
uh-huh I would want no trouble no
trouble uh-huh so I could get out as
fast as I could and I'd probably go to
prison for just something so asinine and
stupid like just rage you know over
something down like a Coachella incident
yeah I'm through that probably you know
stealing one of my dogs oh I could see
that happening
someone's know if you have had to have
an inappropriate or funny last name what
would you choose I miss is coming from a
girl named backup butts
mmm listening her name is Becca butts
well the very first lady that ever
showed me how to beep was named Shanna
Glasscock oh that's a WoW take yeah I
would take that last name something
oddly elegant about that I don't fully
know what you ask someone snow if aliens
came to earth what things what thing
that humans do regularly would be the
hardest to describe to them hmm just
speaking yeah that's true I think that's
very true ignorant slang Oh okay
someone's to know I gotta know what's
the walk out of Worst Cooks pre-planned
no heck no so you are on Worst Cooks the
television show on the Food Network yeah
I told them I was a vegetarian uh-huh
and what happened
they just kept forcing everything not
vegetarian and I try to put up with ever
so long and then when they put a
chicken's foot in my mouth with toenails
what I had to call it yeah
here to go yeah egg I walked out at that
moment Wow they tried everything to get
me to come back we won't do that again
we won't do it again and I just I was
just so hurt that they did that to me
because they knew I was a vegetarian and
that sucks man yeah that's also like the
most you can do to someone that's
politely say around me I was so clear
about you know my stance and stuff and I
think they just sort of played with that
and maybe some people would wouldn't be
light on that but like when I saw the
top horn nails ya know that coming off
of the chicken's foot she was like just
bite down oh no I was like I couldn't no
I can't believe it got boundaries and
yeah I had a threshold yeah it's an
honest reaction
I believe I did that they couldn't
believe it that the person that was
politely reminding them that they're a
vegetarian wasn't anyone walks out like
that it's not like plan but I'm sure it
was a great television I don't I've not
seen it I've not asked the moment you
want to relive things like I don't even
want to know how they portrayed it I
don't want to know what people are
saying there's certain things you don't
need to know yeah yeah this is like
pretty pretty girl dude yeah I did an
episode of Cupcake Wars
with my friend and I haven't watched it
back because it was also just a chaotic
day um yeah to PHA or not to pack Coolio
was on the episode with us and he got in
a fight with the judges because they
interrogated him about putting a full
chunk of lemon in the cupcake and he
said he did in and then he did fever
dream I know it's going back and pretty
sure my face is just completely confused
the whole time that everything was that
your partner no my partner was my friend
Hannah and neither one of us knew how to
bake so it's all pretty much alive
anyway
I have and and then we got we he got
kicked off the first shot and we got
kicked out the second round and we were
very ecstatic to be done so that's all
changing in one room oh right yeah I
always like grown men and growing women
including myself like hey bud you just
want to turn around you know like okay
it was just the weirdest side of it yeah
it's like meant to like exacerbate fears
and anxieties and just get your work
done yeah yeah it's a very chaotic
environment I'm very glad that I didn't
have to work there full-time yes someone
someone tweeted I know you've talked a
little bit about being typecast in the
past do you regret taking any of the
roles that may have led to that no I
don't forget him no no yeah I mean you
talked about it to that like the
typecasting is kind of like now merging
into a role that you'd want in the
future but it's like evolving the kind
of way I mean the moment the moment that
I like tried to play against my typecast
or my stereotype I wasn't working
oh yeah yeah so it's like webs and then
I just said always why I make a good
living doing what I love that's great
and you get to live in Palm Springs with
you no I do not
yeah it's great a lot of people asking
what was it like working with Britney
Spears and crossroads
Britney Spears is awesome such a sweet
girl
she was very young at the time she was
1901 I didn't realize like that's how
young you guys were yeah that's nuts
we're very very young and she just came
out with I'm a slave for you after that
so it's like if you could like put it in
the time I have you know where she was
in life but I have nothing but the best
thing to say about Britney because she
was always so nice and just yeah and
grateful and there's just no gossip or
any type of well that I have for her
she's a hustler and also you guys are so
young at that time like you're just
trying to make it happen just hard a lot
of me imagine like
every single you know camera I mean I
can't even imagine it like that's how
unrelatable her whole life is is that
you see the photos of people taking
photos of her and it's so unimaginable
like when will you ever experience that
in your life that's superstardom on
another level yeah I you know on set
there was just like so many people like
we'd always have to there's just fans
everywhere yeah there's no sense of
privacy it's got a really good really
good attitude that's great very cool
okay last question before we wrap up
someone to know what's the most
embarrassing thing that's ever happened
to you on any set honey said um well
there's can I talk about a premiere yeah
of course
so crossroads premiere in Louisiana
yes we did - we did LA in Louisiana and
Louisiana was like Brittany's hometown
right so the fans were just I mean it
was epic it was like it was just so many
people and she got there so she went in
first with like about I would say like 5
to 8 security okay then like maybe Zoe
went maybe I think me and and then and
yeah thank you I was the last one
actually so I'm walking down and posing
and everything and all of a sudden I get
thrown to the ground I'm just like yeah
like I mean we're talking he's thrown to
the ground because one of her hired
security guards for the night saw that I
was a runaway fan thank God your
co-starring in this movie I mean by Sam
you like picked up over and set outside
oh my god dry the tire was so sweet he
was like so horrified like he didn't
even know we didn't know what to do yeah
and I think that that was like a rapper
tonight I was walking down the red
carpet but at that time like press
wasn't so yeah like they were always
looking for like trouble and stuff but
hands down I was like probably that's
embarrassing thing
ever been through and you know that
there's like fans out there years later
that still have that same memory that
I've seen that I got you bodies man holy
[ __ ] that's embarrassing
Taryn thank you so much for being here
this was super fun before you go um
every guest that makes time for us gets
a personalized fortune cookie from us
and to them there's no meat in it that I
know of so nice it's more about the
fortune right yes ma'am
where'd you get it um I think it might
be deep inside perhaps we are right we
carefully tuck them in ourselves
[Laughter]
personally it is
there we go let's dude they have to say
good news you can eat glue that's all
that's great there we go
a real optimistic way to start your
Wednesday um Taryn where can people find
you online if they don't know and what
you're up to if they like to follow
social media stuff yeah Taryn Manning
Terry Manning Instagram Twitter Facebook
and then um if you want to go t
remaining calm my website cool any new
music coming up yeah I have music coming
out for the 31st but we'll be past that
I mean I'm gonna have music coming out
on the show come on I can't it came out
on the show yeah yeah I saw lots of
music very very exciting um thank you
getting so much this was super fun and
make sure if you haven't already check
out the music and obviously aren't just
new black you've probably already done
that but just a friendly reminder we'll
see you guys next time another episode
not too deep goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep
2deep back whatever struggles you're
facing from depression and anxiety to
trauma and grief better help can connect
you with a professional counselor in a
safe and private online environment it
is so convenient you can schedule secure
video or phone sessions as well as chat
and text with your therapists and
anything you share is completely
confidential and best of all it's a
forward
ball you beautiful listeners will get
10% off your first month with the
discount code grace so get started by
going to better help calm slash grace
fill out a questionnaire to get matched
with the counselor that you'll love
today not too deep as a production of
grace Helbig incorporated producer and
edited by Melissa Dumont's writing by
Diane Kang a production assistants by
Katrina Henning post-production sound by
Chris Henry and an extra special thanks
to Flula for the theme music
[Music]